[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
France d'en bas
bienvenue sur le plateau de Tout le
monde en parle l'émission qui kiffe sa
race
[Musique]
Arielle Dombasle bonsoir on vous
explique tout de suite Julien Drey très
triste parce qu'il s'est disputé avec
Mélenchon
il a refusé un cache donc fait un peu la
gueule
d'arrêter de fumer sans patch
je vous ai apporté un patch c'est gentil
voilà je vais vous le mettre là
maintenant
c'est pas la peine
regardez il y a des trousses vous pouvez
mettre le pain voilà mon petit Laurent
vous allez me faire plaisir essayez ça
vous allez voir vous serez le meilleur
humeur tenez et on colle ou vous voulez
non c'est la frontière
[Musique]
Ariel bonsoir donc je vais donner tout
de suite le secret de votre forme et de
votre beauté comme ça ça sera réglé vous
avez déclaré je ne mange pas d'animaux
comme disait Marguerite Yourcenar je ne
digère pas les agonies évidemment quand
on dit un truc comme ça on n'a plus
jamais envie de manger un morceau de
viande
mais vous avez déjà entendu les animaux
pleurer oui voilà il pleure avant d'être
tué moi je sais pas et oui alors je sais
bien même les huîtres ça va jusque là
tout ce qui est vivant qui bouge qui a
bougé j'en mange pas c'est quand même
bizarre parce que vous avez des origines
mexicaines si ma mémoire est bonne et
vous êtes contre le régime aztèque
alors Ariel dans tous les cas on vous a
vu récemment en photo dans Paris Match
superbe merci
[Musique]
alors Arielle Dombasle votre nom c'est
encore mieux carrielle d'emballe puisque
votre vrai nom c'est Ariel Laure Maxime
sonnerie de Fromental votre arbre
généalogique remonte à Charlemagne mais
il paraît que l'arbre de généalogique de
tous les Français remonte à Charlemagne
donc votre grand-père était diplomate et
ça a été un des premiers à dire non au
régime de Vichy voilà il voulait pas
rester il est parti quoi ah oui il est
parti et à l'époque c'était courageux
c'est vrai que tardivement ça l'était
moins mais être le tout premier
diplomate à dire non et à rejoindre de
Gaulle c'était héroïque à l'époque vous
croyez que vous seriez la femme de
Bernard-Henri Lévy si votre grand-père
avait été collabo
oh là là ça serait difficile quand même
ouais ouais exactement la même je ne
serai pas exactement la même
alors votre grand-père donc était
ambassadeur de la France Libre en
Amérique latine et au Mexique et votre
grand-mère qui est morte à l'âge de 101
ans je dois dire ce qui vous laisse
quand même quelques années
mes modèles elle mange quoi votre
grand-mère
manger des animaux c'est vrai
mais peu très peu donc cette grand-mère
vous l'avez adoré elle vous a permis de
côtoyer pendant votre enfance des gens
comme Octavio pass Carlos Fuentes
Gabriel Garcia Marquet c'est une
poétesse c'est un écrivain une peintre
alors votre père c'est un industrielle
français mais qui avait monté des usines
en Amérique notamment dans le
Connecticut où vous êtes né et au Canada
mais en fait c'était un aventurier un
archéologue ce qui explique d'ailleurs
qui passait son temps à faire des
fouilles au Mexique et ce qui explique
aussi votre enfance mexicaine par le
même passion du Mexique passion des
civilisations disparues et c'est vrai
que quand je pense à mon enfance j'étais
environnée de statues à steaks
les dieux des civilisations disparus
d'ailleurs certains me faisaient très
peur
ça va mieux avec le patch
bien mais alors bon drame votre mère
meurt du cancer vous avez 11 ans à ce
moment-là et vous dites que vous en avez
jamais remis
c'est traumatisant enfin chacun le vit
comme il peut mais moi je n'en ai pas
parlé pendant
pendant 15 ans c'était un sujet que je
me parlais jamais jamais et quand on
m'en parlait quand on posait des
questions je faisais semblant de pas
comprendre bon ben voilà ça c'est des
membres de chagrin
était un homme qui avait énormément de
succès féminin et quand il entrait dans
une pièce toutes les femmes le
regardaient il était très très beau et
voilà il a été très aimé des femmes donc
après le décès de votre mère votre père
se remarie avec une dénommée Laurence de
Lubersac et vous vous avez beaucoup de
mal à accepter cette femme vous avez
dit mon adolescence c'est un no man's
land cette femme que j'admirais beaucoup
qui était une femme extrêmement
éclatante extrêmement brillante et j'en
avais un petit peu peur parce qu'en même
temps elle avait pris la place de ma
mère mais mais ça rendait mon père
heureux donc tout ça est très très
compliqué alors vous reportez votre
amour sur votre grand-mère et donc vous
commencez à vivre à ce moment-là entre
la France et le Mexique vous devenez ce
que vous êtes aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire
un personnage inspiré à la fois par
l'aristocratie française et en même
temps par votre gouvernante indienne ça
comptait beaucoup j'avais d'un côté
toute la famille de mon père Jean chaton
en Bourgogne très comme il faut où
j'avais peur d'aller d'ailleurs parce
que j'étais la petite sauvage mexicaine
je mettais des petits souliers vernis il
fallait très bien se tenir à table ça
m'impressionner et puis au Mexique
j'avais une toute autre vie j'étais
beaucoup avec les domestiques finalement
vous montez votre premier spectacle de
théâtre dans une chapelle désaffectée au
fond de fond du jardin vous êtes
toujours oublié de venir actrice enfin
déjà tous les enfants sont des acteurs
parce que on joue aux gendarmes au
voleur au cow-boy au docteur je suis sûr
que lui a beaucoup joué au docteur et
alors donc
et donc bon les enfants s'amusent
beaucoup jouent beaucoup puis après ils
viennent adultes et ça s'arrête et les
acteurs ont ça sur cette immense
privilège de continuer à jouer et les
tout quoi les criminels les jaloux les
héros les cavaliers seuls les suicidés
on joue tout donc à 18 ans vous
débarquez à Paris parce que Mexique pour
le théâtre c'était un petit peu
compliqué vous pouvez des cours de
théâtre des cours de chant jusqu'en 1978
où Eric rommer vous offre le premier
rôle d'un film qui s'appelle Perceval le
Gallois donc à partir de là votre
carrière c'est un refus de choisir entre
des films intellos et le cinéma
populaire les films intello il y a eu
robe grillés il y a eu Raoul rouït il y
a eu Cédric j'en oublie sûrement mais
les films populaires il y a eu les deux
papas et la maman il y a un Indien dans
la ville donc vous allez comme ça
alterner oui vous savez bon bah les
acteurs ils choisissent pas beaucoup ils
sont choisis en fait et mais je n'ai
jamais voulu je n'ai pas l'esprit
sectaire et j'ai jamais voulu faire
partie de d'un petit ghetto intello ou
du film purement d'auteur je j'avais
envie de tout jouer l'autre grand
événement de votre vie c'est l'amour
merci
[Musique]
et voilà
votre première rencontre avec Bernard et
Lévy vous avez 18 ans vous souvenez de
ça ben oui oui séance de dédicace
il écrit cette phrase génial plusieurs
fois le mec il écrit Ariel en attendant
en tout cas pour moi ça a été très fort
comment pourrais-je ne pas aimer un tel
homme avant Bernard il est Vivi vous
étiez avec un médecin de 30 ans votre
votre aînée en fait
je
voilà
un homme un médecin qui avait 30 ans de
plus que vous période assez mouvementée
mouvementé mais mais il a été la
première personne qui qui m'a aimé et
puis je cherchais un père et une mère
dans une seule personne et cette
différence d'âge ça correspondait à ce
que je voulais à l'époque Olivier à
l'époque fauché dans un grand
appartement de la rue de tilsite qui
donnait sur l'Arc de Triomphe ça allait
quand même oui ça allait sauf que il y
avait beaucoup d'huissiers qui venaient
frapper à la porte mais enfin ça c'était
moins drôle vous étiez avec lui quand
vous avez rencontré Bernard Henri Lévy
non non parce que en plus maintenant il
adore Bernard Henri Lévy
à l'époque vous jouez la petite
Catherine de helbronn mise en scène de
rumeurs sur scène et vous vous revoyez
ça devient très romanaise parce que il
vient vous voir au théâtre ensuite vous
revoyez à Milan vous allez à Scala enfin
voilà c'est très succiniste
pour moi c'est évidemment une histoire
un peu magique je ne dis pas que je n'ai
pas souffert parce que les choses
n'étaient pas simples les gens ne sont
jamais libres tout est très compliqué
mais la vie est comme ça mais quand on
rencontre l'amour et ben il faut y
croire et se dire que tout va s'arranger
si on part perdant alors rien ne
s'arrange et moi c'est vrai que je suis
restée
Backstreet girl comme on dit
longtemps mais je les mets en secret et
c'était merveilleux un vrai coup de
foudre
ah non non non non non non
alors le problème quand même c'est que
quand vous rencontrez Bernard il a dit
que vous avez ce coup de foudre pour lui
et lui réciproquement bien entendu il
est marié il vient d'avoir un deuxième
enfant les choses sont passées à plein
et vous dites les seuls témoins de ses
amours illégitimes c'était les
concierges d'hôtel les groom vous avez
vécu dans le péché Ariel et bien oui
c'est vrai mais vous savez je dis on a
vécu dans le péché parce que quand comme
ça l'amour vous tombe dessus de manière
si violente et bien en général les gens
ne sont pas libres les gens ils ont tous
une vie etc et on entre dans le péché du
moment où on peut faire souffrir les
conjoints bon et donc on est obligé
d'entrer dans tout l'univers du mensonge
et tout ça et c'est bon c'est vieux
comme le monde mais c'est difficile à
vivre voilà alors après le péché
heureusement miracle un jour vous vous
mariez
je me tuerai oui probablement je me
tuerai oui tu vois chérie
je sais je ne suis pas des HL quand même
tu vois chérie prouve-le toi d'abord
quand vous voyez Alain Delon et Rosalie
qui se séparent après toutes ces années
après 15 ans
vous dites quoi vous dites que
finalement même les choses qui semblent
éternelles ont une fin moi j'ai toujours
vécu avec l'idée que ça n'arriverait pas
et que je ne serai pas quitté que les
choses
s'arrangeraient toujours
merveilleusement mais malheureusement et
là autour de moi et on le voit bien et
c'est comme ça quelquefois les amours
finissent et je dois dire que
ça casse les gens plus que tout les
chagrins d'amour c'est probablement
ça vous laisse en miettes
alors on a beaucoup de questions par
mail vous savez maintenant ici les
téléspectateurs peuvent poser des
questions aux invités il suffit de
regarder sur internet la liste des
invités de la semaine suivante donc j'ai
des questions pour vous et notamment sur
la maternité pourquoi n'ayez pas eu le
besoin avec Bernard et David d'avoir un
enfant mais je ne sais pas c'est très
étrange mais j'ai toujours
toujours eu peur j'ai toujours pensé que
je ne serai pas à la hauteur d'avoir un
enfant que je ne sais pas moi j'étais
comme vous je voulais pas d'enfant quand
j'étais plus jeune jusqu'à l'âge de 40
ans je voulais pas d'enfant et puis je
me suis dit que finalement quand je
serai vieux avec un plaid sur les genoux
au bord de la mer
ça serait triste comme ça très égoïste
que moi-même j'ai tellement adoré ma
grand-mère et puis et puis ça s'inverse
c'était elle mon enfant c'est vrai que
c'était elle mon enfant imaginez
ça donne du moins ça donne du piment à
la vie quand même qui s'accroche à
l'héroïne ça donne plus mais bizarrement
c'est vrai que maintenant d'un côté je
n'ai plus de famille et puis je n'ai
plus je n'ai pas d'enfant donc voilà je
suis une sorte de
d'électrons libre comme ça alors Ariel
vous êtes très croyante
la première fois que j'ai vu un crucifix
j'ai pleuré avez-vous déclaré mais oui
parce que je suis entrée dans une église
au Mexique ça ça l'église près de chez
moi qui s'appelait iglesiad Alassane et
puis vous savez au Mexique il y a
beaucoup de représentations du Christ
extrêmement réaliste en bois avec des
avec des gouttes de sang etc et j'ai vu
cet homme crucifié j'étais très enfant
et j'ai tout de suite pleuré je me suis
dit mais c'est une c'est une chose
atroce pourquoi pourquoi est-ce qu'une
torture cet homme ça m'a fait pleurer
j'ai une passion pour la figure du
Christ oui parce que parce que il me
semble l'homme le plus émouvant qui soit
et cette cette douleur et puis et puis
cette idée qu'il est quand même la
personne qui a souffert pour le monde
entier qu'il a voulu par sa mort
et bien c'était un message
révolutionnaire aimez-vous les uns les
autres ces révolutionnaires et ça ça a
changé la face du monde
que vous avez appelé votre dernier album
extase
extase en partie parce qu'il y a
beaucoup d'extase différents
alors voilà quoi ça ressemble
la vie
[Musique]
l'album s'appelle extase
alors
on pourrait croire qu'en fait ce qu'on
vient d'entendre c'est le produit du
studio ou du mastering donc je vous ai
fait une surprise
vous me regardez comme ça
j'ai peur que vous refusiez j'ai demandé
à un piano ah ben voilà le piano je vais
vous chantiez je vous chantiez en direct
là maintenant
chanter ce que vous voulez mais comme ça
pour nous là ce soir non ici elle a
envie de chanter ta taille yoyo
qu'est-ce qu'il y a sur ton grand
chat tu peux venir tu peux dire que
la chanson de la lame de Fontenay
si vous préférez
on sent que des efforts ont été faits
pour Arielle Dombasle le pianiste a été
repeint en même temps que le piano
[Musique]
alors
un standard américain
Liza Minnelli un truc un peu comme ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
attendez attendez attendez attendez
on va faire autre chose
j'ai demandé au pianiste de préparer un
certain nombre de chansons de morceaux
il va vous les jouer et alors ça va vous
évoquer quelque chose arrière et vous
allez donner votre avis ou répondre aux
questions que ces morceaux posent ça
s'appelle l'interview piano
alors s'il vous plaît maestro premier
morceau
[Musique]
Johnny Johnny ma gueule ma gueule
alors quoi ma gueule qu'est-ce qu'elle a
ma gueule
qu'est-ce qu'elle a votre gueule
c'est une moi je dois dire déjà que
Johnny
comme tous les Français je l'aime
beaucoup et ça gueule aussi
et puis j'ai eu la chance de chanter une
fois avec Johnny au Parc des Princes ben
si si et alors je me rappelle
de vous
la trouvez comment votre votre visage ce
qu'il faut c'est s'aimer suffisamment
pour ne pas être obsédé par soi voilà
[Musique]
oui souvent on me dit ça que je le suis
et moi vraiment je ne me sens pas du
tout snob non non
comme d'habitude c'est my way my way
alors les habitudes ont mauvaise presse
on dit ah oui l'habitude tu l'amour etc
et moi je trouve que les habitudes c'est
ce qu'il y a de plus délicieux dans la
vie si on n'avait pas d'habitude
qu'est-ce qu'on deviendrait prendre son
bain c'est une merveilleuse habitude
oui et puis il habite où
mais l'habitude il y a rien de mieux moi
j'ai quand j'ai l'habitude que que mon
mari rentre à la maison j'entends son
pas j'ai l'habitude je le reconnais il
ouvre la clé de la porte j'ai l'habitude
et puis le soir j'entends son souffle
sur l'oreiller j'ai l'habitude j'adore
et d'habitude
on continue maestro
[Musique]
jamais
ne vous jamais
que je t'aime c'est ça que tu m'aimes
que tu aimes que tu aimes oui j'avoue
jamais
bon ben moi je trouve qu'il faut avouer
justement
il faut avouer son amour
le cri du cœur
Non Non mais écoutez il faut avouer son
amour genre je ne dis rien etc on le
fait on ne dit jamais assez de choses
tendres et gentilles il faut avouer aux
gens qu'on les aime très bien
Sam est une femme
avec une femme et bien
bon moi écoutez je suis quelqu'un de
très sage mais
je trouve qu'il y a autant de sensualité
qu'il y a d'individus et donc que les
gens préfèrent les femmes ou les hommes
ou tous les deux et tout ça n'est-ce pas
Thierry et bien alors
le bilan vous savez que maintenant dans
cette émission Ariel nous faisons des
bilans d'interview nous allons faire le
bilan de cette interviews parce que vous
en êtes content pas contente est-ce que
des questions que j'aurais oublié de
vous poser je vois que vous repartiez
dans la loge en disant ah non j'aurais
dû dire ça Thierry Ardisson c'est le
bilan ah le bilan c'est que j'ai
l'impression d'avoir été un peu trop
bavarde hein
au 14e siècle il y a dans
[Musique]
magnéto Serge pour ou contre le
réchauffement de la planète au moment
des vacances j'aime bien
est-ce que vous êtes Franck Dubosc pour
ou contre les trentenaires qui chantent
ils aux enfants des soirées privées
pour
bien sûr voici venu le temps je ne suis
pas 39
[Applaudissements]
année difficile aussi Franck parce que
c'est l'année où vous avez perdu votre
votre père oui mais vous réussir mais il
a
il a
j'ai du mal à parler de ça alors
il a pas vu l'Olympia donc ça ça vous
avez des réactions de Lionel Jospin
en fait dans toute cette histoire
c'est vos allusions la taille de son
sexe qu'est-ce que tu veux dire par un
peu court pour être président
le matin quand tu te regardes dans la
glace est-ce que tu te dis ouais cool je
suis David Hallyday
non
non je me dis pas ça non je me dis que
j'aurais mieux fait de dormir 2h de plus
j'ai pas été
nickel tout va bien moi j'ai quand même
appris que Johnny Hallyday était ton
père
est-ce que vous avez décidé d'arrêter
les émissions de télé à la con
bon moi je suis ici ce soir donc non
en fait je pars du principe que je n'ai
pas à aimer les homosexuels et je vais
vous expliquer pourquoi c'est pour moi
les homosexuels n'existent pas
exactement comme les hétérosexuels
n'existent pas je considère qu'il y a
une sexualité par personne que la
communauté homosexuelle c'est quelque
chose qui m'échappe comme si par exemple
on faisait une communauté des mecs à
lunettes blond avec des doubles foyers
qui mettent des baskets ADIDAS
et il a piqué ton business
est-ce qu'il y a des sosies de Johnny
Hallyday beaucoup non oui je connais
assez Johnny Hallyday qui m'a dit une
phrase inoubliable il m'a dit je suis
bien content que Johnny se soit
stabilisé sentimentalement parce que
j'arrivais plus à suivre
du second excusez-moi deux secondes je
suis vraiment c'est presque fini
excusez-moi pardon excusez-moi Thierry
Ardisson bonsoir excusez-moi de
d'interrompre l'enregistrement des
missions je suis vraiment désolé la
télévision vous a apporté la gloire le
pouvoir l'argent la réussite
duquel vous vous débarrasseriez le plus
facilement aujourd'hui donc
ça rend pas mégalo comme ça de harenguer
des des foules de plusieurs milliers de
personnes avec la voix booster avec son
image sur des écrans géants c'est
totalement c'est une c'est une drogue
dure mais en même temps comme c'est le
métier que j'avais choisi ça peut pas le
seul truc que je sais faire et puis ça
me rapporte beaucoup de pognon j'ai du
mal à renoncer à l'autre côté
deux ans de travail
500 candidats au départ 500 ce qui fait
1000 nichons bienvenue
c'est la Techno Parade de Jack Lang
c'est encore plus chiant que la fête des
mères c'est absolument pas
Jack Lang combien y aurait-il de Gay
Pride par an
mais peut-être qu'il y en aurait plus
aucune puisque finalement nous aurions
profondément transformé les valeurs la
vie serait une énorme Gay Pride
l'abeille devait tirer en plein vol
pendant deux jours par une cinquantaine
de mâles et d'ailleurs le mal il tire et
il laisse les les couilles et la
sur le truc d'ailleurs tire et il meurt
il tire son coup en plein vol comme un
vulgaire Stewart
un mec décidé qui a décidé de donner sa
vie vos une armée entière cette guerre
ne peut pas être gagnée on peut pas les
Américains ont compris qu'il se
faisaient descendre les deux tours du
World Trade Center avec 12 mecs décidés
et quatre cutter il y a des parents qui
éduquent leurs enfants leur disant si tu
te fais péter la gueule en tuant
d'autres personnes tu seras un héros et
ne me dites pas que ça peut pas arriver
parce que c'est ce qui se passe ce gosse
de 17 ans il y a des gens qui donnent de
l'argent à sa famille il y a des gens
qui lui donnent la ceinture de bombe
ces gens-là ont des noms ce sont des
organisations certaines basées en Arabie
Saoudite ce sont des états la Syrie
l'Irak ce sont une partie des dirigeants
palestiniens c'est l'autorité
palestinienne elle-même qui a détourné
le fric de l'aide humanitaire le fric de
la Communauté européenne pour pour
fanatiser des gaz je baise les pieds de
tous les pacifistes du monde entier à
contre a commencé par les Israéliens et
les Américains parce que faut avoir une
sacrée paire de couilles pour être
pacifiste en Israël et je leur baise les
pieds et je leur dis merci d'exister
Bruno délinger
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir On est à Sainte-Foy-lès-Lyon il
y a 41 ans parcours au départ assez
classique école de commerce diplôme et
puis dans les années 80 vous créez une
radio libre avec Jean Edern allier exact
ensuite entre deux petits boulots vous
écrivez un livre où vous évoquez des
tours de cristal qui disparaissent dans
l'Apocalypse c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est
vrai c'est la conclusion même du livre
puisque c'est une immense vision de
l'Apocalypse qui clôture ce premier
livre et je les voyais comme un symbole
de New York bien sûr prémonitoire
peut-être mais la grande aventure de
votre vie justement c'est l'Amérique
d'abord la Californie ensuite New York
vous adhérez au rêve américain et en
1997 vous fondez une société
à aider les sociétés américaines qui
veulent investir en Europe et
inversement également vous organiser des
expositions pour de jeunes artistes
américains vous installez vos bureaux
47e étage du World Trade Center ces
bureaux vous les adorez je les adore
vous dites une transparence des murs en
verre une table en verre un lieu de paix
de sérénité de réflexion dans ce dans
cette ville de New York et une ville
extrêmement bruyante c'est un lieu où il
y avait un silence merveilleux presque
magique les gens qui étaient dans les
étages supérieurs par exemple pouvait
passer l'hiver entier dans les nuages
dans le coton et nous on était à la
bonne à la bonne hauteur c'est à dire
qu'on avait parfois le coton aussi mais
parfois on était aussi au dessus des
nuages et puis souvent on était dans un
soleil radieux comme le temps
new-yorkais alors le soir des fois vous
quittez votre bureau du World Trade
Center vous marchez sur le pavillon vous
vous retournez et vous dites c'est pas
ouais je suis dans le Wall tra
complètement alors le World Trade Center
vous en parlez très bien dans votre
livre parce qu'en fait c'est une ville
en l'air il y a énormément de gens qui
vivent là-dedans c'est une utopie des
gens de toutes les races de toutes les
classes de toutes les religions 115
nationalités et qui vivaient
harmonieusement et puis un jour ce jour
c'est le 11 septembre 2001 comme vous
dites les ils ont pété mon
bureau interview vérité
[Musique]
alors Bruno délinger le 11 septembre
2001 votre réveil sonne à 4h du matin
pourquoi parce que Victoria a un
déplacement professionnel et elle va à
saint-paul-manapolis et elle part très
tôt et elle part de l'aéroport de New
Work dans New Jersey d'où un certain
nombre d'avions vont décoller aussi
longtemps un avion suicide moi je me
lève vers 6h30 alors votre femme
Victoria est parti pour pour ses
affaires vous prenez votre métro
normalement pour rejoindre le World
Trade Center et à 8h45 vous êtes avec
vos deux employés vous commencez votre
journée de travail le stagiaire est en
retard
Arnaud c'est les trains du du nord de
New York du quête j'en ai normale j'en
ai merveilleuse et à ce moment-là vous
entendez vous dites dans votre bouquin
un énorme vomissement vous reconnaissez
tout de suite le bruit d'un avion oui
parce que je voyage beaucoup et encore
une fois la Une des magies de ce lieu
c'était le silence donc je le remarque
immédiatement comprenez pas sur le
moment vous relevez la tête et au moment
où vous relevez la tête vous entendez un
impact d'une violence inouïe et trois
secondes plus tard vous voyez passer par
la fenêtre devant vous oui les débris
des poutrelles vous voyez je suis médusé
je vois passer devant devant mes
fenêtres et de et mes employés sont
médusés aussi on voit passer des tonnes
de de morceaux de ferraille de kérosène
de verre et on sait pas ce que c'est on
comprend pas c'est très inquiet à ce
moment-là non non parce que le bâtiment
aussi vraiment très très longuement et
il tente pendant une vingtaine de
secondes 30 secondes je sais pas
exactement et à tel point que je suis
obligé de tenir une de mes employés
parce que j'ai peur qu'elle s'effondre
et dans le bureau tout tout bouge les
tableaux un tableau se casse la figure
une statuette vraiment vacille fortement
mais non on n'a pas peur on pense que
je leur dis je les ai remarques idiotes
je leur dis vous inquiétez pas c'est un
avion qui a percuté le bâtiment
oui parce qu'en 45 il y a une erreur de
pilotage j'avais amené déjà un avion à
s'écraser contre le l'Empire State
Building donc j'étais pas oui c'est à ça
que je pense immédiatement et je me dis
c'est un avion un pilote qui a mal mais
je pense pas un avion de ligne
certainement pas et je pense pas à un
attentat encore moins
votre seule réflexion à ce moment-là si
vous dire c'est con on va perdre des
journées de travail parce que vous êtes
un entrepreneur vous êtes un Amérique
n'est pas pris évidemment conscience de
l'ampleur du drame et puis à ce
moment-là un de vos employés ouvrent la
porte qui donne sur le couloir et à ce
moment-là quand même vous voyez de la
fumée ça sent le kérosène oui alors que
notre bureau était dans un état tout à
fait acceptable on ouvre la porte et là
c'est déjà une certaine dévastation
parce que les
plafonds sont effondrés il y a de la
fumée il y en a d'autres kérosène
épouvantable plus tard quand j'évacurai
il y a même des de l'eau qui coule dans
les dans les cages d'ascenseur de
service
on voit pas très bien il y a quelqu'un
qui s'enfuit dans la pénombre et mes
employés ont peur parce que c'est une
femme qui a une qui a subi la tenda de
93 et quand je leur dis de partir il
suffit immédiatement cette femme alors
vous restez seul dans le bureau vos
employés sont descendus alors assez
tranquillement d'ailleurs vous faites
vos sauvegardes informatiques vous
raccrocher vos tableaux vous éteignez la
photocopieuse c'est bien je fais le tour
je fais le tour
je fais le tour je coupe tout et je fais
une sauvegarde informatique
dans votre bureau vous dites je vais
rester plusieurs jours sans revenir donc
voilà je veux que ça soit bien que ce
soit que ça soit rangé et alors on
entend rien parce que les haut-parleurs
ne marchaient pas les haut-parleurs
d'alerte sur le 47e étage on était en
train de refaire les les
systèmes d'alarme donc j'ai pas de
sentiment d'urgence immédiate vous
prenez l'escalier assez tranquillement
au bout d'un moment il y a 47 étages à
descendre évidemment
la descente va durer 50 minutes sans
beaucoup d'affolement d'ailleurs
effectivement les gens un petit peu
comme moi trouvent qu'ils ont une
journée de travail interrompu je trouve
ça désagréable mais tout le monde est
très calme très civique très ordonné et
en descend le long des des 47 étages
pendant que il y a du trafic qui se
densifie pas de panique les gens parlent
des affaires en cours il y en a qui
commentent les résultats sportifs de la
veille quoi comme voilà comme ça à un
moment il y a un type quand même qui
reçoit un texto qui lui annonce que la
tour numéro 2 a été attaquée mais
personne panique les gens continuent à
descendre il y a quand même un truc qui
est un peu plus inquiétant un moment
c'est quand vous un brûlez vous double
et là vous dites dans votre bouquin les
gens détournent assez pudiquement le
regard
et je pense que ça fait partie de ces
mécanismes de défense qu'on a tous eu
dans des circonstances difficiles
on voulait peut-être pas voir ce qui se
passait et puis en plus on comprenait
pas parce que ces gens étaient n'avaient
plus de peau n'avaient plus de cheveux
était complètement brûlés et tout au
long de la tour dans les escaliers de
c'est tout on entendait s'écrit
priorités priorités et les gens
descendaient bien sûr en priorité et
puis il y a des pompiers qui montent
aussi arnacher alors évidemment il y a
une espèce de va-et-vient comme ça dans
ces escaliers mais tout ça est avec
beaucoup de calme comme on l'a dit vous
arrivez sur le parvis du World Trade
Center oui je suis sorti en souterrain
les gens qui sont sortis sur le parvis
et qui étaient partis en même temps que
moi eux sont décédés donc je suis sorti
en souterrain en sortant dans la rue je
me suis retourné j'ai vu ce bâtiment en
feu là j'ai compris que c'était très
grave et puis effectivement
je me suis retourné une deuxième fois et
je l'ai pas vu parce qu'il y avait ce
monstre qui qui arrivait sur nous le
nuage tueur le killer cloud le nuage
tueur et ce que j'appellerais plus tard
aussi vraiment le baiser de la mort
parce que ça dépasse l'entendement en un
instant alors que dans cette rue il y
avait une vie extraordinaire de service
de secours qui était dans tous les sens
de voiture de d'ambulance de gyrophare
partout de sirène soudain ça va sur nous
cette masse monstrueuse
et tout devient silencieux et c'est la
nuit et donc là à ce moment-là l'esprit
est plus capable de
procéder à l'analyse et c'est le
subconscient qui reçoit tout et on est
terrorisé et maintenant je comprends ce
que c'est qu'un traumatisme parce que ça
dépend tellement ça dépasse tellement
l'entendement que le cerveau est plus
capable de l'accepter ce nuage il avait
qu'elle consistance moi j'appelle ça de
la matière fluide parce que il y a une
accumulation extrêmement dense de
cendres de débris de gravats de
poutrelle de verre j'ai gardé la cendre
que j'ai accueilli sur mon sur mon
costume ce que je considère qu'elle est
sacrée et qu'effectivement
dans toute cette cendre il y avait
peut-être des morceaux d'hommes
alors à ce moment-là vous vous réfugiez
derrière le pilier d'une banque vous
êtes tout noir évidemment couvert de
cette chose quoi de cette matière fluide
comme vous dites vous avez plus
d'oxygène vous pouvez plus respirer
parce qu'évidemment ce nuage a envahi
toute l'atmosphère vous croyez être mort
en fait à ce moment-là oui ou mon
subconscient est persuadé que que je
suis mort et alors ça se traduira par
des choses invraisemblables parce que un
petit peu plus tard quand je me promène
dans la rue
mon esprit continue à capter des signaux
de ce que la vie continue mais à
l'intérieur je suis persuadé d'être mort
alors j'ai l'impression de devenir
complètement fou et j'ai l'impression
que
quand on parle de ces gens qui sont
venus amnésiques en a retrouvé il y a
quelques jours seulement je comprends
tout à fait ce qui s'est passé ils ont
juste pas résisté
vraiment devenir alors là il y a un
agent du FBI qui vous fait entrer dans
la banque bon ben vous êtes sauvé vous
retrouvez d'autres gens d'ailleurs
là-dedans qui sont aussi noirs que vous
alors là évidemment il y a les bons
sentiments il y en a beaucoup parlé ici
aux Etats-Unis dans les médias mais
aussi vous découvrez la nature humaine
c'est à dire qu'il y a des profiteurs il
y a des pilleurs il y a des vautours on
vous propose par exemple un jour des
bureaux gratuits vous êtes vachement
content il tient les mecs sont
solidaires ils meufs des bureaux
gratuits et le type vous dit que ça
c'est valable pendant deux mois et qu'à
partir de la fin du deuxième mois il
faudra payer 2000 dollars par poste de
travail ce qui fait beaucoup d'argent en
tous les cas beaucoup plus cher que ce
que vous payez wall Trade Center c'est
difficile de découvrir cette
aspective de la nature humaine enfin
c'est pas une découverte non plus les
hommes sont les hommes et simplement
dans ces circonstances ça prend un
relief particulier effectivement alors
tout ça en plus dans une psychose
terrible un état de guerre quoi peur de
l'entraxe à ce moment-là vous cherchez
avec Victoria votre épouse des masques à
gaz sur Internet enfin je veux dire
c'est est-ce que un sentiment de
vengeance vous a aidé à ce moment-là au
début j'ai eu
une haine violente pour tous ces gens
maintenant c'est le mépris et rien de
plus Ben Laden vous l'auriez tué
Ben Laden
je pense que
tous mes idéaux en voler en éclat et que
j'ai plus aucune certitude aujourd'hui
sur ce que c'est que sur la punition
qu'on doit infliger à des gens pareil et
que je croyais que les idéaux s'étaient
éternel et j'étais contre la peine de
mort et maintenant je me pose du sérieux
question parce que on peut pas c'est
très se laisser traiter comme ça c'est
pas possible vous trouvez normal le sort
que les Américains réservent aux
prisonniers de la base de Guantanamo par
exemple
moi je trouve que
si c'est des criminels ils sont encore
bien traités parce que
quand on inflige en souffrance aux gens
on prend ses responsabilités d'abord et
on les assume jusqu'au bout
vous pensez qu'il méritent la façon dont
on les traite je pense qu'ils n'ont pas
volé
la guerre en Afghanistan vous étiez pour
les bombardements de moi
pour la guerre mais après j'ai compris
que c'était important de répondre et je
crois que je me suis senti rassuré
rassuré de ce que les gens qui sont
supposés nous défendent nous défendent
et oui je pense qu'elle était nécessaire
cette guerre pour moi il y a aucun doute
c'est vrai qu'un an après les attentats
du World Trade Center l'anti
americanisme n'a jamais été aussi fort
en Europe
55% des Européens juge le comportement
américain pas étranger à ses attentats
c'est beaucoup 55% des Européens en
France c'est 63% des gens qui pensent
n'ont pas que les Américains n'ont pas
volé c'est un peu exagéré mais que leur
comportement est pas étranger aux
attentats je trouve quelque chose de
monstrueux là-dedans parce que comment
un très rapidement
quand on dit ils n'ont pas volé vraiment
on oublie on oublie tout ce qui s'est
passé et il n'y a pas d'acte il y a pas
de cause il y a pas de défense de cause
qui justifie un acte pareil
vous pensez que c'est une attitude
munichoise
je pense ce qui a certains relents
Munich quoi dans tout ça et je pense que
on est très injuste à l'égard des
États-Unis parce que ils prennent des
responsabilités souvent que le monde
refuse de prendre et après tout les
Européens ont des idéaux et il faut
prendre les moyens de de les défendre
finalement alors vous savez qu'on
soupçonne l'Arabie Saoudite de
financière Kaïda sur les 19 pirates il y
en avait 15 qui étaient saoudiens mais
les USA évidemment ne peuvent pas s'en
prendre à l'Arabie Saoudite aussi
directement les familles des victimes le
font les familles des victimes du 11
septembre ont attaqué au tribunal des
banques saoudiennes des organisations
caritatives et trois membres de la
famille royale est-ce que ça remet pas
en cause votre attachement au système
américain de voir que finalement leur
vrai ennemi l'ont pratiquement identifié
mais que pour des raisons mercantiles
ils peuvent pas s'y attaquer parce que
l'Arabie Saoudite et le pétrole
oui vous savez je pense que c'est pas le
système américain qui est en cause dans
cette histoire c'est l'intérêt des états
et on sait que les États parfois se
conduisent pas forcément comme il le
souhaite et le rêve américain ou
tout ce qui est ça n'a rien à voir et je
crois alors actuelle que effectivement
tout le monde
y compris nous en Europe sont bien
heureux d'avoir cette source
d'approvisionnement pétrolière donc
oui c'est du réalisme ce qu'on appelle
la politique c'est ce qu'on appelle le
réalisme politique vous êtes d'accord
avec ce qui est prévu à la place du
World Trade Center sur ce qui s'appelle
aujourd'hui Ground Zero
aujourd'hui je suis je suis un peu déçu
parce qu'il était présenté parce
qu'effectivement ça n'a pas l'élan qui
avait le World Trade Center pour moi le
World Trade Center tout le monde a vu
comme un symbole de domination là encore
et puissance américaine c'était un
témoin du du génie humain
et on verra ça c'est les concours sont
pas encore terminés je pense que tout le
monde va se remettre sur la sur la
planche à dessin si les tours sont
reconstruites à cet endroit là vous
retournerez vous y installez
immédiatement allez immédiatement parce
que j'ai un grand attachement au lieu je
crois que
ça serait bien de pouvoir retourner
là-bas et puis il y avait une vue
magnifique vous arrivez à vivre avec ça
en vous maintenant
j'arrive à vivre avec ça au moins c'est
pas facile parce que c'est comme un
invité que vous avez que vous n'êtes pas
sollicité et il se manifeste selon son
bon gré et ça c'est horrible merci
ça s'appelle wall Trade Center 47e étage
et c'est chez Robert Lafont
[Musique]
j'accueille maintenant Abdes
bonsoir bonsoir chérie Mariani donc qui
rentre d'Irak Samad Moussaoui donc vous
avez 35 ans vous êtes professeur en
électrotechnique à Montpellier vous êtes
le frère de Zakaria Moussaoui qui est
inculpé depuis décembre 2001 ça a été le
premier inculpé par la justice
américaine pour les attentats du 11
septembre il est soupçonné d'avoir été
le 20e pirate aux ordres du réseau
Al-Qaïda si chefs d'accusation pèse
contre lui donc 4 sont passibles de la
peine de mort le procès débutera le 6
janvier 2003
ce verdict en plus est une véritable
épée de Damoclès sur les relations
franco-américaines puisque Zakaria se
Moussaoui votre frère est de nationalité
française et qu'en France comme vous le
savez évidemment on a aboli la peine de
mort alors vous publiez Zacharias
Moussaoui mon frère chez de Noël impact
avec la collaboration de la journaliste
Florence boukila interview vérité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
alors on va commencer par le
commencement votre père était carreleur
au Maroc quand il a rencontré votre mère
qu'elle époque avait 14 ans alors on n'a
jamais su en fait si votre mère
avez-vous lu de toute force quitter
son foyer pour se marier avec votre père
ou au contraire si elle avait été mariée
de force
ma mère dit qu'elle a été mariée de
force ma grand-mère dit que c'est elle
qui a voulu se marier mon oncle dit que
c'est elle qui a voulu se marier ma
tante dit que c'est elle qui a voulu se
marier dire l'essentiel n'est pas là en
tout cas c'est clair que les années plus
tard elle en a gardé une une douleur
quoi une souffrance elle s'en est
largement exprimée donc l'essentiel pour
elle il est là en fait c'est que ce
mariage au départ c'était une douleur
quoi pour elle alors deux filles
naissent et puis votre père décide
d'émigré en France en 1965 sur la côte
basque et vous laissez vous donc en 1967
et votre frère Zakaria en 1968 et 3 ans
après en 1971 vos parents divorcent et
vous partez tous les deux avec votre
mère à Mulhouse
ou votre mère a trouvé du travail alors
pourquoi Mulhouse
alors je ne sais pas j'étais trop jeune
je ne sais pas je sais qu'on s'est
retrouvé dans un dans le dans un
orphelinat qui s'appelle le Home
Saint-Jean oui parce que votre mère peut
pas vous garder donc elle vous met à la
date j'imagine que ça doit être des
moments terribles pour elle et c'est
vrai que cet endroit pour nous c'était
un endroit un petit peu d'effroi en même
temps on était rassuré parce que il y
avait des parquets en bois il y avait de
gros édredon il faisait chaud c'était
bien chauffé et en même temps on était
un petit peu effrayé parce que on avait
pas nos parents et puis on voyait tous
ces gens nous disait c'est un orphelinat
donc nous on prenait chaque jour comme
si on était des invités comme si on
allait partir demain mais à chaque jour
on succédait ça dure un an oui ça a duré
plus d'un an ouais ça a marqué zakariace
vous pensez cette séparation de sa mère
je pense que ça a marqué toute la
famille je pense que ça marqué toute la
famille parce que dans cette orphelinat
je pense que c'est des endroits un petit
peu où il y a pas d'autorité parentale
on les éducateurs ça rapporte pas la
famille ça remplace pas les parents mais
alors en plus quand votre père vient
vous voir vous partez courant parce que
votre mère vous a expliqué que votre
père est un homme méchant qui lui a fait
du mal donc quand vous voyez votre père
s'approchait pour vous parler vous
partez en courant et d'ailleurs il finit
par se lasser il vient plus et bien un
jour votre mère vous dit bah vous voyez
vous allez tomber bah oui c'est triste
c'est pas quelque chose mais c'est
quelque chose qu'on ne comprenait pas
nous d'un côté on avait notre mère qui
nous disait que qui nous montrait son
affection qui nous avait sirpé de
l'orphelinat pour nous c'était c'est
formidable c'était une héroïne pour nous
et puis dans l'autre côté on avait ce
père qui était absent et qui était
accusé de tous les mots donc pour pour
nous c'était pas difficile de le fuir
c'était pas difficile donc quand il est
arrivé vous partiez en partant au
courant en partant en courant d'ailleurs
je me je raconte cet épisode dans le
livre il venait nous chercher il nous a
fait monter dans une 4L et en deux deux
on s'est regardé avec mon frangin on a
ouvert chacun une porte et on a sauté en
courant et on s'est sauvé
la plus revue pendant des années parce
que c'est là c'est il a fini par se
lasser
alors un jour votre mère annonce que
vous allez quitter l'est de la France
pour vous installer à Narbonne et
Zakaria c'est lui il veut rester à
Mulhouse parce qu'il espère devenir
joueur de handball professionnel et
c'est une vraie déchirure pour lui ce
départ pour pour Narbonne
oui c'est vrai c'est quelque chose qui
l'a marqué c'est quelque chose ce même
des années plus tard même quand il était
la fac il en parlait encore avec avec du
regret parce que il s'éclatait il était
dans un club à sptt Mulhouse il jouait
handball il était reconnu il avait le
poste de pivot il était très performant
il était très apprécié et puis du jour
au lendemain ma mère nous a sorti une
carte à la maison elle nous a dit bon on
va aller dans le sud au soleil on va
voter on va décider ensemble quelle
ville on va choisir on a pris une carte
on a mesuré sur la carte à distance avec
la mer la plus proche c'était Narbonne
donc on a dit on va aller à Narbonne en
tous les cas pour Zakaria ce quelque
chose se brise il en gardera toujours
une certaine rancoeur vous dites dans
votre livre une certaine amertume
moi je dirais c'est comme une fêlure une
petite fêlure qui vient se mettre après
une autre fêlure
je me suis rendu compte avec du recul
que il y a pas d'éléments clés il y a
des petites fêlures des petites marques
des coups de canif
troisième fêlure l'arrivée à Narbonne
alors là c'est terrible parce que vous
êtes marocain mais vous êtes assez noir
de peau et vous avez l'accent alsacien
alors évidemment quand vous arrivez à
Narbonne pour les gens là-bas vous êtes
espèce de martien en quelque sorte ça a
fait quand il faut s'arriver comme ça et
que vous parlez comme ça c'est pas très
courant
voyez voilà ça fait plutôt sourire mais
voilà maintenant quand on est adulte on
comprend mais quand on est enfant c'est
pas quelque chose d'évident
alors il faut vous expliquer à tout le
monde la vérité il faut vous expliquer
vous êtes arabe en fait donc c'est en
général on n'a pas besoin de l'expliquer
vous êtes obligé d'expliquer ça
des fois on nous prend on nous prenait
pour des Antillais
quand nous quand on vous prend pour un
entier qu'on est en France et savoir
c'est plutôt sympathique le contact est
plutôt sympathique les Antilles le rhum
la biguine c'est plutôt sympa et un
contact qui se fait mais comment on dit
arabe maghrébin là tout de suite ça
devient plus lourd alors adolescent vous
êtes plutôt sage parce que vous avez
qu'une peur c'est d'avoir un casier
judiciaire et et de pas pouvoir faire
des études poussées et d'ailleurs à
l'époque Zakaria c'est très très droit
il dit attention il faut pas qu'on fasse
des conneries quoi exactement je crois
que c'est le passage à l'orphelinat qui
nous a qui nous a fait prendre
conscience de ça qu'il fallait qu'il
fallait pas laisser passer les
opportunités de formation et depuis très
jeune c'est mon frère qui me poussait
qu'il me disait attention il faut qu'on
fasse des études non faut pas qu'on se
laisse aller parce que dans le quartier
on habitait on habitait la cité razimbo
à Narbonne c'est une cité HLM des
bâtiments de 4 étages une quinzaine de
blocs des terravagues
les gamins qui traînent qui squattent
dans les halls qui tiennent les murs
l'environnement c'est pas un
environnement très très épanouissement
très très ouvert quoi c'est c'est le
monde dans la stagnation on attend que
le temps passe végétatif voilà alors
côté étude ça va pas si mal mais côté
familial ça s'arrange pas du tout un
jour vous promenez dans la rue à
Narbonne avec votre votre frère
zakariace et il y a quelqu'un qui vous
arrête comme ça et qui vous dit mais
vous n'êtes pas les fils Moussaoui vous
alors vous dites oui oui bien sûr oui
vous connaissez notre père et l'homme
vous répond oui j'étais en prison avec
lui
notre première réaction ça a été de se
regarder
et puis de regarder s'il y a des
personnes qui entendaient
parce que tout de suite on s'est senti
mal à l'aise
et puis tout de suite après on a demandé
des nouvelles
imaginez en fait arrêter dans la rue par
quelqu'un qui vous dit qu'il est en
prison avec votre père
[Musique]
donc c'était c'était quelque chose de
une déchirure de plus oui c'est de
nouveau un petit canif alors à ce moment
là ça va un peu mieux pour votre frère
Zakaria s'il rencontre Fanny qui est
blonde à la peau blanche et aux yeux
clairs et ils ont une histoire d'amour
qui va d'ailleurs durer 10 ans mais les
parents de Fanny sont un racisme
affligent
il n'aime pas
c'est ce que dit Fanny c'est ce que
disait Zacharia
moi j'ai pas vu de démonstration de
racisme virulents vous voyez c'était une
indifférence et comme je disais dans le
livre peut-être que Fanny a le tort de
de dévoiler les propos qui se tiennent
chez elle dans l'intimité de la maison
donc il y a un mépris qui s'installe et
une distance
au début nous vous savez quand qu'on
était plus jeune on pensait que les gens
racistes c'était uniquement des gens qui
n'étaient pas cultivés que c'est des
gens qui qui avaient peur de l'autre qui
n'avaient jamais été en contact avec
l'autre donc on pensait que
de montrer tel qu'on est de se montrer
tel qu'on était
d'essayer d'être ouvert de communiquer
d'aller vers l'autre que ça faisait
tomber les barrières
non non c'est c'est pas aussi simple que
c'est plus compliqué que ça à l'époque
vous découvrez que votre frère Zakaria
n'aime plus votre mère
oui c'est terrible
vu qu'il la regarde mais pas comme on
regarde une mer il la regarde froidement
avec distance avec recul faut dire
qu'ils avaient des conflits ils avaient
des l'âge de 14 ans il avait des configs
mais très très durs moi je comprenais
pas j'ai jamais compris ça
ils étaient capables de
s'engueuler de se disputer de 18 heures
à 2h du matin
c'est épuisant surtout quand ça se passe
tous les jours alors parlait beaucoup
avec votre mère pour se disputer
apparemment mais votre mère vous a
jamais parlé arabe à la maison déjà je
me rends compte qu'effectivement on
parlait pas arabe à la maison
on connaissait pas les gens de notre
famille on connaissait pas notre culture
on connaissait pas notre tradition le
peu de fois où on a posé des questions
par exemple quand on veut parler on veut
apprendre une langue on a besoin d'être
mis en confiance si à chaque fois que
vous voulez apprendre une langue je
crois que vous dites un mot de travers
vous prononcez mal on se met à rire de
vous ça coupe toutes les vérité quoi
de religion la religion
musulmane je m'étais jamais été apprise
ce qui a fait que vous n'avez pas de
repère en fait c'est on était ignare on
va dire ce qui est on dit ignare
je dois dire que je connaissais enfant
je connais c'est plus le catholicisme
que la religion musulmane en Alsace il y
avait pas de séparation de l'Église et
de l'État je me rappelle à l'école
primaire et ben on allait au catéchisme
moi je dise au curé je suis musulman
mais bon à part le mot musulman je
savais pas très bien ce que ça ce qui
avait derrière et puis bon il nous
racontait des histoires bon je savais
donc les gens fêter Noël je savais
pourquoi il y avait là tout ça je savais
pourquoi mais le ramadan je savais pas
pourquoi la fête de la naissance du
prophète Mohamed je savais pas pourquoi
pourquoi les gens faisaient la prière
comment ils faisaient la prière je
savais pas pourquoi des ignards donc
vous fréquentez pas beaucoup d'Arabes
vous dites même que votre mère est assez
xénophobe et que ce qu'elle disait dans
la bouche de d'un Français de souche
sera paru comme des propos extrêmement
xénophobes limites Front national quoi
mais écoutez moi quand j'étais quand
j'étais plus jeune avec mon frère ça
nous gênait ça nous gênait beaucoup ça
nous gênait beaucoup je n'avais pas
peut-être les mots pour dire
si tel propos et xénophobe ou pas mais
on se sentait très mal à l'aise pourquoi
parce que dès qu'il y avait un maghrébin
c'était les moqueries c'était
c'était nous renvoyer une image qui est
pas une image positive donc on se
sentait mal à l'aise moi en fait alors
vous n'êtes pas non plus intégré
évidemment parmi les Français de souche
et vous racontez dans votre livre une
anecdote assez terrible vous êtes à
Mulhouse vous êtes rue kaiserberg dans
un espace vert qui est en bas de de
l'immeuble où vous habitez et vous jouez
aux billes avec des petits copains en
rentrant de l'école jusqu'au jour où le
petit garçon vous dit je ne peux pas
jouer avec vous alors mes parents me
l'ont interdit alors vous dites pour ce
soir non c'est pour tout le temps
pourquoi parce que vous êtes des
ça c'était notre première expérience par
un proche
et c'est vrai que moi ça ne m'est resté
en mémoire parce que c'était quelqu'un
que je côtoyais c'était quelqu'un avec
qui je m'amusais c'est quelqu'un avec
qui je rigolais et puis du jour au
lendemain il y a eu ce changement cette
cassure
mais ça c'est c'est de la New York à
côté de d'autres expériences alors il y
a un événement important c'est le 14
juillet 1989 vous êtes victime d'une
agression raciste
à Narbonne donc quand vous courrez voir
les policiers pour chercher un abri pour
qu'il vous protège il vous accueille
avec des gaz lacrymogènes parce que pour
eux un arabe et coupable d'office alors
ça Zakaria se le voit il en souffre
presque plus que vous et là aussi ça a
dû faire partie des petites fêlures qui
ont
tout à fait
un type qui m'arrête dans la rue il me
tape sur les poches je me retourne il
met une droite un soir de 14 juillet je
m'en vais en courant au coin de
l'immeuble je tombe sur une patrouille
de police qu'est-ce que je fais le
réflexe j'ai la bouche ensemble je
m'arrête je demande de l'aide puis là il
reste il me regarde et puis le type il
arrive il veut me finir
et puis un policier matrape par les
cheveux il me sort une bombe lacrymogène
et il me gaz je me sauve je m'évanouis
j'ai la chance que de mélaniement un
restaurant dans lequel il y a des amis
qui s'entraînent dîner ils sont sortis
ils sont venus voir qu'est-ce qu'il y
avait ils m'ont réanimé ils m'ont emmené
à l'hôpital et ils ont fait ils ont fait
fuir le le type mais c'est pas c'est pas
le coup de poing qui m'a fait mal et
c'est pas le coup de poing qui m'avait
révolté ce qui m'avait révolté à
l'époque parce que j'étais jeune j'étais
un jeune homme c'est le manque de
réaction des des flics français
j'imagine c'était que d'accord il y
avait la cohue d'accord c'était le 14
juillet d'accord il y avait du monde
mais c'est que entre deux le choix il a
évité fait
forcément c'était moi et et c'est vrai
que pendant longtemps j'en ai gardé un
ressentiment et pendant longtemps ça a
tué la confiance il a fallu plus
d'expérience plus de
plus d'épreuves pour relativiser alors
Zakaria souffre plus que vous finalement
de cette mésaventure et puis après c'est
la guerre du Golf alors là d'un seul
coup il a le sentiment
d'appartenir à l'autre monde celui qui
est attaqué par les Américains
je dis il je dirais ont et les étudiants
et puis toute une sortie de partie de la
population parce que moi je me rappelle
les positions de Jean-Pierre Chevènement
bien il était il était contre
l'attaque en Irak il y a d'autres moyens
que de bombarder des populations civiles
maintenant il faut raisons garder on
n'était pas on n'était pas pour Saddam
Hussein ah non absolument pas la
dictature le gazage des populations
Kurdes on n'était pas pour ça nous ce
qu'on voyait uniquement c'était une
population civile qui allait se faire
taper dessus et en même temps que cela
on avait des gens qui ils étaient là ils
s'éclataient il se il se répandait en en
réjouissance presque devant le
la grandeur et et la beauté des frappes
chirurgicales qui qui ont fait des
massacres de population
qui avait des populations civiles
derrière c'est les bombes
alors Zakarias fréquente à ce moment-là
la cafétéria de la cité universitaire de
Montpellier il rencontre des étudiants
étrangers
donc il est soumis sûrement à ce
moment-là certaines influences
et ils partent assez rapidement en
Angleterre et au début il revient voir
Fanny tous les quatre mois au départ il
revient assez souvent finalement
mais il commence à changer votre épouse
Fouzia je prépare le CAPES donc elle
fait des études
et lui lui explique un jour où il
revient comme ça qu'il faut pas que les
filles fassent d'études petit à petit
vous deviez étranger à vous d'une
certaine façon au départ avec mon épouse
Fouzia on comprenait pas
Fouzia elle a fait des études de
biologie elle a fait un troisième cycle
de neuropsycho pharmacologie elle
préparait un CAPES de biologie
les années précédentes avant qu'il parte
en Angleterre mon frère était le premier
à l'encourager il faut savoir que mon
frère il n'avait qu'une idée qu'une
obsession c'était la réussite
professionnelle son objectif c'était
monter une entreprise qu'on fasse pour
export entre les pays du Maghreb les
pays du Golfe et c'est pour ça qu'il
était parti en Angleterre pour améliorer
ses connaissances en anglais donc
quelques mois plus tard on le voit
revenir et qu'est-ce qu'on trouve dans
son discours on fait pourquoi tu fais ça
de toute façon reste à la maison c'est
mieux à la maison et puis de toute façon
tu sais les femmes après tout
vous le voyez changer alors il se met à
porter la barbe il se rase le crâne il
commence à porter des pantalons à
mi-mollet et un jour l'une de vos sœurs
Djamila s'habille pour sortir habillé
comme on commence à vie ici et Zakaria
se la regarde et lui dit mais tu vas pas
sortir habillé comme une dire que
là vous vous comprenez d'un seul coup
qu'il est passé de l'autre côté
ça ça m'a fait mal au cœur et je me suis
dit qu'il y avait quelque chose qui qui
était vraiment
brisé chez lui
moi j'ai pris ça vraiment pour pour
vraiment un signe de détresse
alors il avait été recruté par une Secte
Wahhabite et vous vous lui donnez à ce
moment-là des brochures qui critiquent
le wahhabisme et finalement au lieu de
le ramener dans le droit chemin si on
peut dire ça ça ne fait que renforcer sa
détermination je connaissais pas j'étais
pas du tout averti moi par rapport à à
cette secte la secte Wahbi tous les
cotomistes j'étais pas du tout avertir à
ça je connaissais pas
et puis donc je savais qu'en Angleterre
je lisais les journaux je savais qu'en
Angleterre il y avait des groupes
extrémistes je savais qu'il y avait les
groupes où habite donc j'allais dans une
mosquée à Montpellier il y avait la
documentation sur les Wahabi je lui
donne moi j'avais le réflexe mon frère
c'est un universitaire lorsqu'il veut
s'informer sur un sujet il se fait une
bibliographie il se constitue une
documentation donc à partir des
informations que je vais lui donner il
va pouvoir avoir des éléments pour être
critique moi c'est le raisonnement naïf
que j'avais mais c'est pas comme ça
qu'on lutte contre une secte là c'est
l'échec assuré quand on a quelqu'un qui
est embrigadé dans une il faut d'abord
cultiver la relation il faut cultiver
les sentiments l'attachement car c'est
par le cœur qu'on arrive à faire sortir
quelqu'un d'une secte c'est pas par la
raison dans un premier temps mais la
raison elle est là elle est importante
parce que quand on vient avec les
arguments et que l'on montre à quel
point le Wahabi c'est une secte qui est
apparue à 250 ans et qu'on montre à
partir des arguments de la religion que
leur propos que leur propos
d'excommunication des populations
entières leur propose de légitimation de
l'assassinat et du meurtre et que ce
sont des choses qui sont infondées qui
n'existent pas dans l'islam sunnite faut
savoir que les théologiens musulmans
sunnites depuis 250 ans il montre du
doigt et ils mettent en garde contre le
wahhabisme si on montre cette réalité là
là la réaction elle est plus la même
mais vous parlez du wahibisme comme
d'une secte enfin c'est quand même la
religion officielle de l'Arabie Saoudite
officiellement en Arabie Saoudite on
appelle ça le royaume moi habite c'est
un fait
si on interroge les la population
d'Arabie vont vous dire on est hamli et
quand l'idéologie wahhabite pénètre en
Europe c'est pas en disant on est Wahabi
parce que habite ne sont pas aimés ils
vous disent ils disent la population
musulmane nous sommes Hamadi à dire une
des quatre écoles de jurisprudence qu'on
appelle l'islam sunnite et par cette
porte là ils vont essayer de rentrer et
petit à petit ce qu'ils vont essayer de
faire c'est faire croire à la population
musulmane à la jeunesse musulmane qu'ils
sont eux les tenants et les garants de
la légalité et de la légitimité
religieuse musulmane alors vous vous
êtes sunnite tout à fait vous êtes d'une
tendance qui s'appelle les abaches
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
quoi parce que vous savez les Français
connaissent pas très bien la deuxième
religion de leur pays c'est quand même
un drame les Ardèche ce sont des
sunnites qui ont peut-être plus pris
conscience que d'autres d'accord qu'il
fallait aider la communauté musulmane à
lutter contre l'extrémisme le problème
c'est que les voies habitent détiennent
l'argent du monde musulman vous dites
qu'ils occupent 90% du linéaire
islamiste en vente libre leur livre sont
ceux qu'on trouve le plus le plus
facilement en Europe
oui ça c'était c'est une deuxième
constatation quand j'ai vu mon frère me
glisse et des mains donc j'ai voulu
aller me renseigner mon documenter
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait ben le réflexe
je vais dans une librairie maghrébine
là où pour 150 francs à l'époque 150
francs on ressort avec 10 bouquins et
puis quand on discute avec le libraire
et vous apprend que en réalité les
livres il les payent pas on lui donne et
on lui dit ben tu les payera quand quand
tu veux je sais pas quelle libraire peut
fonctionner comme ça donc l'argent c'est
important parce que le fait c'est comme
dans un supermarché vous rentrez vous
trouvez 80% des linéaires qui sont
remplies de l'idéologie wahhabite avec
autobistes le jeune qui est né en France
qui comme moi n'a pas d'histoire n'a pas
connaissance de la culture musulmane pas
de repère qu'est-ce qui va croire il
pourrait croire que ces représentatifs
du monde sunnites alors que ça n'a rien
à voir est-ce que vous pensez que les
livres ouais bits devraient être
interdits à la vente en France par
exemple à tout à fait bien sûr mais
c'est pas l'unique moyen
on peut pas remplacer l'éducation c'est
c'est irremplaçable c'est une nécessité
moi je suis enseignant moi je veux le
bien
moi je veux que les jeunes que je forme
au lycée ben ils soient utiles pour
eux-mêmes pour leur famille pour la
société j'ai pas envie qu'ils se laisse
embrigader par un groupe extrêmeiste qui
se passe sauter ou qui tue des gens et
je voudrais que les gens bonne volonté
et ben ils se révoltent eux aussi dans
quel sens mais qu'on sache que derrière
l'idéologie de la haine et la Terreur il
y a le wahhabisme il y a l'idéologie de
cette rotobe et qui a des gens qui ont
de l'argent et qui poussent cela pour
qu'il y a beaucoup de zakariace
Moussaoui dans les banlieues françaises
je ne sais pas mais je sais que
potentiellement il y a une il y a une
vraie détresse sociale et que les
wahhabites et les adeptes de cette
coutoub ils savent utiliser cette
détresse sociale pour capter les gens
c'est sûr qu'il faut un profil
particulier c'est sûr qu'il faut être
réceptif c'est pas tout le monde mais il
y a plusieurs niveaux vous savez il y a
les rabatteurs ce sont les adeptes de
l'idéologie de cette photo et puis après
il y a ceux qui mettent les bombes
et je sais qu'en France il y a beaucoup
de rabatteurs vous croyez qu'en France
aujourd'hui le politiquement correct
interdit de d'en parler de ça par peur
de l'amalgame pour éviter finalement que
les gens considèrent tous les tous les
musulmans comme des terroristes en
puissance moi je pense qu'il faudrait il
faudrait casser ce tabou et il faudrait
essayer de lancer le débat mais
moi j'apporte ma pierre
vous aussi d'autres peuvent la porter et
c'est clair que si on casse ce tabou là
les choses vont aller on va pas refaire
le monde non mais les choses vont un peu
mieux comment ça peut aller mieux alors
zakariase vous l'avez pas revu depuis
1995 vous avez un contact avec lui
depuis son arrestation
non non il m'a adressé un message dans
une de ces lettres il me disait qu'il
m'embrassait et mis à part ça non j'ai
pas eu de contact
vous pouvez pas aller aux États-Unis
parce que vous craignez d'être gardé par
les autorités américaines jusqu'au
procès comme témoin donc vous n'y allez
pas oui c'est pour ça oui c'est pour ça
ce qui est terrible avec Zakaria c'est
que dans ces déclarations il persiste et
signe c'est-à-dire que même maintenant
il est au secret dans une prison
américaine il a pas de repentir
je vous fais pas dire c'est terrible
moi
j'attends le moment où
peut-être il y aura un recul qui sera
pris par lui et lui remettra en cause un
peu les l'idéologie qu'il a amené là où
il se trouve et
où il manifestera un repentir j'attends
ça avec beaucoup d'impatience
imaginez que votre frère Zacharias
Moussaoui regarde cette émission est-ce
que vous avez quelque chose regardez
votre caméra est-ce que vous avez
quelque chose à lui dire ben moi si je
pouvais avoir mon frère en face de moi
je lui dirais que tout homme tant qu'il
est vivant il a la possibilité de
changer
et que c'est pas parce qu'on a fait des
erreurs dans le passé que on peut pas
être meilleur
et que il faut avoir le courage de
reconnaître ses erreurs et d'expliquer
en quoi on a fait des erreurs parce que
dans sa situation
son cas c'est devenu un cas qui est
emblématique et il faudrait pas qu'il y
en ait d'autres qui suivent son exemple
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
magnéto Serge est-ce qu'on vous a déjà
appelé Francis hamster
qu'est-ce que vous aimez le plus en moi
ton charme fou merci mon amour alors
qu'est-ce que vous aimez le moins en moi
ça cette question est nulle
à votre avis il y a des chances pour
comprendre
de quoi toi et moi ou
qu'est-ce que vous aimez le plus chez
vous
pas grand chose qu'est-ce que vous aimez
le moins chez vous et tout
pour la classe ouvrière
quel que soit ses défauts
il aurait quand même mieux valu que je
spin soit président non
il était il était premier ministre avant
et je crois que malheureusement ça n'a
pas changé grand-chose
Olivier Besançon
est-ce que vous ne regrettez pas d'avoir
été de ceux qui ont fait battre Jospin
non parce que je fais pas du tout partie
de ceux qu'on fait au spa et d'ailleurs
je crois que même Lionel Jospin ne nous
a jamais pointé du doigt
j'avais tellement les pétales avant
d'arriver je me suis dit il va me dire
tes sados ou maso ou je sais pas quoi
cette époque là c'est fini j'avais peur
de la question vérité tu sais qui donne
la mauvaise mine hein
il y avait une école privée de garçon où
il y avait que des garçons et l'école
m'a accepté comme unique fille et unique
externe et puis il y en avait un qui
m'avait écrit une lettre en me disant
que tu es la plus belle de l'école et
voilà le travail et ouais ouais de
l'autre côté il avait pas le choix non
plus
il y en a une qui a compris c'est une
compilation des obsessions solaires
siennes on l'a beaucoup dit aussi la
misogynie vous dites les cinq exercices
j'en ai eu mais avec lac ok moi je dis
ça tout le monde trouve ça miso vous
dites ça tout le monde trouve ça génial
que j'aime beaucoup je souhaite dans ma
maison une femme ayant sa raison sauf
que je pense que la raison d'une femme
c'est justement d'avoir de la déraison
ou la guérison d'une femme ce serait
d'avoir enfin de la raison
la paix
le sexe mène à la violence ou à la
mélancolie
ça c'est tellement c'est tellement
excusez-moi
c'est assez bête ensemble mais peu
importe peut-être quelqu'un de très bien
qui a dit ça mais c'est assez bête
Philippe solaire
alors l'anti interview c'est très simple
je vous donne les réponses et vous me
donnez les questions par exemple acné
à l'adolescence comment s'appelait votre
compagne
franchement ça me ferait mal au cul
est-ce que ça vous dirait de passer un
mois sur une déserte avec Dave
du loft
dans votre vie quelle est la personne
qui vous a le plus influencé
j'ai été administrateur d'une banque
juive pendant 10 ans ce qui est rare
parce que c'est qu'une bande juive
français
quand ils sont juifs quand ils ont mis
la bombe
députés juifs à l'Assemblée nationale
l'Assemblée nationale sur une assemblée
juive
quand ils ont ils travaillent dans les
organisations
ou je ne le défendrai pas moi je vais
vous dire une chose c'est que vous avez
mis la mémoire de votre famille au
service d'une bien mauvaise cause
je ne le pense pas sinon je le ferais
pas merci libère de beauf
[Musique]
dis papa tu aimes les 10 de Marie
Laforêt
moyennement mais c'est pas nouveau je
veux dire j'aimais beaucoup Marie
Laforêt quand c'était une jeune et super
bactérie
reviens une salle de bain que vient
revient
est-ce que sur TF1 la météo est droite
il y a quelqu'un qui présente la
télévision sur TF1 qui a été mis au
placard et pourtant c'est une
personnalité de valeur qui a cherché
vous demander vous allez voir patrice
Drevet Patrice
si on disait du mal de double you Bush
ecoutez moi ce qui me fout la truie
c'est que
il attaque vraiment l'Irak comme
apparemment et on a envie mais bon le
temps qu'il le trouve sur la carte je
pense qu'on a un petit moment
du mal de Stevie
Stevie moi je l'appelle wonders TV parce
que comme Stevie Wonder il a lu aucun
livre
sur 10 j'ai du mal de Joey Starr alors
Joey Star c'est vous êtes fous j'ai vu
Joey Starr tabasser une hôtesse de l'air
j'ai vu Joey Starr tabasser un singe
comme je me situais à peu près entre les
deux
alors aujourd'hui vous êtes comme Selman
Rushdie victime d'une fatwa il y a une
prime vous abattre est-ce que vous savez
de combien est le montant de la prime
[Musique]
à ma tête c'était 500 dollars ce qui
n'est pas beaucoup d'argent
toujours repris pour ceci dit pour
quelqu'un du Bangladesh de pauvres c'est
énorme
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir
peuvent envoyer des mails pour poser des
questions aux invités qui vont venir
dans l'émission C'est sur le site tout
le monde en parle donc j'ai un mail de
Christelle de Tours qui dit Christine
Angot seriez-vous masochiste pour
revenir sur le plateau de Thierry
Ardisson alors que l'expérience semblait
assez négative la dernière fois si ce
n'est pour vous en tout cas pour
quelques spectateurs mais je ne vais pas
voir Thierry Ardisson je vais voir
Christelle voilà donc tout va bien voilà
alors pour ceux qui n'auraient pas vu
les épisodes précédents voici un petit
résumé donc d'abord vous êtes venus
parler ici Christine Angot de votre
livre l'inceste
206 là quand même c'est violent
son père la forcée à manger des
clémentines sur son sexe c'est l'inceste
il a sodomisé seulement après il allait
à la pharmacie acheter de la vaseline je
voudrais savoir parce qu'il fait rire
non non
chérie parce qu'elle s'appelle
Clémentine non
parce que je m'appelle Clémentine
mais voyez mais son père l'a forcé à
manger des clémentines sur son sexe non
non
j'ai entendu les gens rigoler parce que
je me suis dit
voilà donc c'est vrai que
on rigole des fois souvent de choses on
ne comprend pas aussi donc c'est vrai
voilà ensuite Christine Angot vous êtes
revenu pour votre livre suivant qui
s'appelait quitter la ville livre dans
lequel vous racontez votre premier
passage dans tout le monde en parle
alors vous dites alors dans votre
bouquin en parlant de ça Clémentine
Célarié et mentifié débarrasse justifier
à tellrie Angola vu pas le
téléspectateur le public a ri David
Hallyday Harry ils ont ri après le
Thierry Ardisson alu page 206 etc ce
qu'on vient de voir et vous continuez
tout son riz maintenant ils sont gênés
maintenant génie qu'ils sont les invités
fixent le petit écran qu'ils ont chacun
belle invention qui leur permet de
tamiser le réel par sa représentation
Clémentine Jerry parce que les gens
rient parce que je pensais qu'il pensait
à moi David Hallyday on rigole souvent
des choses qu'on comprend pas personne
ne relève solution continue donc Xavier
jeté un vrai froid
vous voulez dire avec ce passage là oui
parce que vous l'avez demandé pourquoi
ils ont ri c'est vrai que la réaction
humaine devant une phrase comme c'est
une réaction humaine c'est une réaction
naturelle je pense que c'est pas une
réaction humaine
chose c'est vraiment un truc c'est une
phrase qu'elle a que la crudité de celle
que j'ai cité de votre précédent livre
donc il s'appelait l'inceste les gens
ris c'est une façon de se défendre
devant une telle violence exactement et
bien les gens ont tort de se défendre
parce qu'à force de se défendre il
protège pas les autres et c'est toujours
les mêmes qui sont dans les places qui
sont à la place d'être attaqués et ça
suffit quoi j'en ai marre mais ce
soir-là Christine Angot vous n'avez pas
quitté la ville vous avez quitté le
plateau et puis à partir de là
remarqué il a essayé de me draguer mais
j'en veux pas vous pouvez pas savoir ce
qu'il y aura marqué dans le prochain
bouquin et ensuite
[Musique]
pourquoi Christine
voilà Christine Angot donc dans le livre
que vous publiez aujourd'hui parce
qu'entre nous c'est une vraie histoire
qui dure c'est un feuilleton donc le
livre s'appelle pourquoi le Brésil on va
en parler publier chez Stock voilà vous
raconter le départ à chaque fois vous
racontez l'émission précédente et vous
venez en parler dans une émission ça
peut durer pendant pendant une vingtaine
d'années moi je serai ravi parce que je
finis par vous apprécier beaucoup je
vais vous le dire donc vous racontez
votre départ de l'émission en fait vous
dites ça m'a un petit peu soulagé parce
que j'étais quand même très
culpabilisé par cette histoire vous
dites que en fait vous aviez pas envie
de sortir ce soir là
c'est quand même très très tard je suis
fatiguée
elle est très fatiguée
il faut aller voir il faut tout ça enfin
bon bref c'est quand même assez bon
maintenant c'est un espace public donc
bon
et oui ben oui ben oui ma femme
vous êtes dans l'ambiance donc bon
j'imagine que bon voilà
bon mais enfin c'est un espace public
quand on écrit des livres c'est la
moindre des choses d'y aller dans cet
espace sinon toute façon voilà c'est
normal quoi j'espère que ce soir ça se
passera mieux et que dans votre prochain
livre vous aurez un truc sympa à
raconter sur la soirée de ce soir donc
je suis là s'appelle pourquoi le Brésil
c'est extrait d'une phrase d'une lettre
que vous retrouvez que votre père vous a
écrit alors il y a pas d'histoire avec
vous les lecteurs ont droit à votre
parcours mental à ce qui se passe
vraiment dans votre tête au moment où
vous écrivez vous dites un jour j'ai
compris non parce que l'écriture devait
être mais ce qu'elle était chez moi
c'est-à-dire vous êtes contre l'histoire
contre les personnages je suis pas
contre je suis pas du tout contre mais
disons que
quand on raconte quand on est dans le
récit quand on raconte une histoire à
mon avis on forcément on se trompe enfin
ça peut jamais être ça peut jamais être
très juste quoi donc la seule chose
qu'on a à faire c'est ce qu'on a entendu
comment ça s'est passé dans sa tête ce
qu'on a ressenti qu'est-ce que c'était
qu'est-ce qu'on a ressenti quand on a
rencontré telle personne ce qu'on a
éprouvé parce que en fait dans la vie on
ne fait que ça quand on quand on parle
quand on arrive à parler de manière un
peu intime avec quelqu'un qu'est-ce
qu'on lui dit bah oui tu vois il est
arrivé il m'a dit ça et ça m'a fait ça
on passe notre vie à dire ce genre de
choses c'est de l'autofiction ça vous
embête quand on dit autofiction oui
parce que si vous voulez l'autofiction
c'est quand même faire de soi un
personnage donc autant dire une
caricature et balader ce personnage dans
dans une histoire donc autant dire une
caricature de vie donc moi
j'appelle ça roman parce que je pense
que c'est inscrit dans la langue qu'on
parle tous alors ça fonctionne assez
bien je dois dire j'ai lu ce bouquin
j'étais assez pris je l'ai vu d'une
seule traite et on rentre dans votre
tête quoi on se rend compte que c'est
pas simple d'ailleurs d'être dans la
tête de Christine Angot dans la vôtre
c'est plus simple quand même c'est vrai
ah quand même oui ça vous déçoit non
mais ça m'étonne mais c'est bien ça
alors ils aventures de Christine Angot
maintenant c'est un peu comme Martine
alors il y a Christine Angot
c'est pas tout à fait comme
ça les aventures de Christine Angot vous
employez beaucoup de noms propres je
crois qu'il y a personne qui n'est pas
son vrai nom dans votre
personne qui n'aime pas son vrai nom je
sais pas qui c'est mais vous dites vous
avez une endroit mais vous dites si on
veut écrire il y a pas de demi-mesure
si vous voulez bien sûr que non il y a
pas de demi-mesure ou alors il y a des
demi-livre et donc bon voilà ouais vous
êtes quand même pas toujours fidèle à
votre Dogma par exemple vous parlez pas
de votre fille Léonore dans le bouquin
ou très peu très peu parce que c'est pas
là c'est pas la question un peu non non
pas du tout là c'est vraiment c'est pas
c'est pas ça que je regardeais c'est pas
ça que j'avais à résoudre à ce moment-là
alors vous ne parlez pas beaucoup donc
de votre fille vous n'allez pas beaucoup
de sexe vous dites je sais pas raconter
je ne sais pas raconter effectivement le
sexe
quand il n'y a pas quand il n'y a pas de
quand il y a un rapport d'égalité je
sais raconter le sexe quand il y a un
rapport d'inégalité parce que s'il y a
un rapport d'inégalité de contrainte
vous êtes obligé de séparer votre
corps et votre tête et donc vous pouvez
garder de la place dans la tête pour
savoir ce qui s'est passé est-ce que
vous avez ressenti alors que je pense
que sinon quand vous êtes dans un
rapport sexuel
bon sans contrainte enfin bon voilà
harmonieux ou je sais pas quoi et bien à
ce moment-là vous n'avez pas besoin de
faire cette cette séparation là et qui
peut marcher ensemble
il y a pas grand chose il y a ça glisse
il y a le sexe dur de votre
amant voilà c'est tout ça glisse ça se
résume à ça remarquable
les lettres de votre père que vous
retrouvez lors d'un déménagement c'est
un peu c'est un peu monté c'est romancé
ça quand même non pas du tout
absolument pas je me vois pas du tout en
train de fabriquer je sais pas quelqu'un
qui fabrique vous fabriquez parce que le
dîner branché à la fin via Beck BD toute
la banque
jalouse
j'ai pas changé une virgule voilà et si
on me dit mais tu n'y étais pas où vous
n'y étiez pas et effectivement je le
fais je n'étais pas mais enfin j'y étais
vous savez quand les trucs passent à la
télé je veux dire on y est donc c'est
public ce sont des choses qui sont
publiques donc j'y étais nécessairement
alors donc comme je disais il y a pas
d'histoire au sens traditionnel du mot
mais il y a quand même une histoire
d'amour avec un critique littéraire dont
vous donnez le nom donc on peut le
donner que ça s'appelle Pierre-Louis
rosinez quand je vois maintenant ce que
vous lui faites vivre ça me venge de
tout ce qu'il a écrit sur moi il a
accepté facilement de voir son vrai nom
dans le livre
vous dites ça aurait été plus violent si
je l'avais appelé Dupont oui donc il est
content oui je pense au bout du compte
enfin je ne sais pas la littérature en
même temps oui enfin vous savez je suis
pas sûr que ce soit les préoccupations
enfin peut-être que si enfin j'espère
que si je veux dire si vous commencez un
écrivain en tout cas c'est quand on vit
avec un écrivain ça peut vous arriver en
tous les cas c'est pas le genre
d'histoire d'amour comme ça qui
transfigurent la vie mais c'est vraiment
la dissection d'un rapport amoureux une
espèce de c'est anti mythologie de
l'amour c'est donc absolument c'est anti
mythologie de l'amour ça ne transfigure
pas la vie mais ça permet de la vivre
c'est à dire que au début du livre bien
bon voilà ça commence il y en a pas il y
a pas d'amour il y a pas de rencontre il
y a personne
ils viennent pas ou alors s'ils viennent
ça va pas et puis voilà et puis
finalement ben ça se passe et
au moment il y avait personne c'était
plus possible c'est à dire que la vie
était difficile et écrire par exemple je
me disais que c'était une chose que je
pourrais plus faire parce que devenir
chez vous par exemple
c'est quand même difficile donc si j'ai
personne quand je rentre chez moi c'est
quand même vraiment difficile et ça
c'est je ne sais pas si les gens ils
pensent en tout cas ça va se vendre
comme des petits pas vous le savez non
non je le sais pas je n'ose pas le
savoir
mais cela dit c'est pas du tout dur à ce
que justement du race c'est quand même
enfin question mythologie de l'amour
elle a contribué je veux dire donc je
pense que je contribue pas à ça
ça va se vendre les gens vont vous aimer
ça vous embête qu'on vous aime pourquoi
ça m'embête c'est bien d'être rebelle
pas être aimé non mais ça c'est le
plaisir
si on est dans la pause effectivement
c'est bien c'est bien de se dire
personne ne m'aime etc bon cela dit moi
j'ai jamais pensé que personne ne
m'aimait en tous les cas les critiques
sont excellentes j'ai pris juste les
mauvaises critiques parce que il y en a
trois mauvaises le reste elles sont
toutes bonnes donc il y a muret dans le
Figaro Magazine qui compare votre
clivage c'est mon choix ces espèces de
de culte du nombril c'est très blessant
c'est désagréable j'ai pas vous dire que
que j'ai dit ça et que vraiment ça m'est
égal mais mais bon si vous voulez c'est
ils sont renvoyés eux-mêmes et donc ils
disent que c'est non-brunique bah oui
seulement c'est l'heure de l'Ombrie
c'est tout alors il y a le magazine qui
est têtu qui vous reproche en ça je suis
pas bien compris vous êtes sûrement
m'expliquer qui vous reproche d'avoir
écrit il y avait deux homosexuels dans
l'immeuble à côté qui promenait leur
chien
oui qu'est-ce que ça grave d'écrire ça
non mais parce que pour eux enfin je
pense que c'est il m'aime bien je veux
dire mais ils avaient besoin de de qu'on
discute de ça parce que pour eux c'était
problématique de voir que c'était le
cliché justement le cliché des
homosexuels avec le chien et le seul
côté Hermès il y a des clichés partout
il y a des clichés effectivement dans
l'amour il y a des clichés dans la
communication il y a des clichés chez
les hétéros il y a des clichés chez les
homo il y a une autre critique qui est
plus terrible celle là c'est toujours ce
fameux pierres insuline dans l'IRL
l'année dernière elle a la même époque
avait sorti la fameuse interview de
Houellebecq où il attaqué les les
musulmans alors lui il dit que c'est pas
une histoire d'amour fou c'est
l'histoire de fou mais pas des vrais
fous fascinants dit-il des petits fous
urbains de simples caractériels
fours d'ailleurs ça devrait rassurer
tout le monde ce sont des petits fous
urbains
nous sommes tous et voilà et c'est ça
qui que moi je trouve bien sûr c'est
l'histoire de petit fou urbain
naturellement voilà alors ils vous
reproche quand même de parler d'érotisme
de la chambre à gaz puisque Pierre-Louis
rosinet vous dites de lui enfin il dit
lui-même qu'il est le seul Juif qui se
cache en temps de P et que vous faites
l'amour dans un appartement rue du Four
c'est que si Le Pen avait écrit ce que
vous avez écrit là il serait fusil déjà
il y a tous des trucs de sujets du four
etc mais enfin c'est tout à fait autre
chose je crois que la personne n'importe
qui ouvre ce livre n'importe qui le lit
et
tomber raide en se disant mais comment
est-ce que on a pu dire que c'était
antisémite ou je sais pas quoi mais
n'importe qui n'importe qui la personne
la plus mauvaise foi bon c'est c'est
vraiment c'est c'est l'inverse c'est
tout le contraire c'est l'idée qu'il
faut quand même pas oublier que dans
tomber amoureux de quelqu'un il y a le
mot quelqu'un et que et bien quelqu'un a
une origine que quelqu'un est né quelque
part ou quelqu'un n'est pas né quelque
part où est juif ou à une famille qui a
été décimée ou c'est ou pas ou etc donc
la question de l'origine dans l'amour
hein est-ce qu'il est bras ce qu'il est
blond est-ce qu'il est comment les yeux
nanana et cetera les cils recourbés par
exemple et bien ça oui c'est à dire tous
les détails physiques sont importants
pourquoi pas parce que c'est beau ou
parce que c'est moche parce que ça
rattache à l'histoire
profonde des
êtres c'est tout donc bien sûr que la
et ça je vois pas qui va me dire le
contraire que la peau que le sang c'est
profondément érotique oui et je vois pas
pourquoi les juifs seraient les seuls à
ne pas avoir le droit d'avoir un
érotisme c'est tout très bien Christine
Angot pourquoi le Brésil chez Stock
magnéto Serge Dominique Voice
benamias et peau craint vont bosser chez
Europe 1
dans les médias c'est ça m'amuse parce
qu'on disait sous forme de boutade que
j'aimais tellement les médias que
lorsque j'allais retiré de l'argent dans
les guichets automatiques je faisais des
interviews aux caméras de surveillance
Depardieu dit une énorme idée si le si
le graphique Khalifa était ce que dit
Noël Mamère ce que dit toute l'Algérie
d'ailleurs la presse l'aurait déjà
démontré comme si la presse algérienne
n'était libre et comme s'il pouvait y
avoir une presse libre en dictature
franchement pour vendre quelques
bouteilles de vin Depardieu pousse quand
même un peu le bouchon très loin est-ce
que le fait d'être père maintenant vous
rend plus indulgent envers votre père
oui mais j'avais déjà fait un peu de
travail là dessus quand même
sinon il y aurait eu mort d'homme
vous êtes trop souvent tôle ouais
longtemps et alors
en plus dure
ça m'a rendu antisocial
tout de suite
on n'a pas assassiné Jacques Mesrine ce
jour-là on assassiné mon père donc vous
me regardez dans les yeux et vous me
dites il y a pas eu de sommation s'il y
a pas eu de sommation il y a eu
assassinat je peux pas vous dire qu'il y
a pas eu de ce match je peux pas venir
puisque je n'étais pas là Monsieur
Broussard n'était pas là il y avait
personne alors il y avait des
inspecteurs bon il y a certainement de
sérieux doute qui ne les ai pas faites
mais c'est au magistrat instructeur a
déclaré la vérité
Mesrine s'était mis en dehors des règles
de l'État de droit il a tué des gens
mais en même temps je pense que ce qui
s'est passé avec Mesrine j'étais
journaliste à l'époque pour nous tous
c'était évident qu'il s'agissait d'une
exécution quand on est dans un état de
droit même les assassins ce qui était le
cas de Mesrine ont droit à le respect de
l'État de droit c'est-à-dire à des
sommations lorsqu'il y a un guet-apens
qui est fait par les services de police
les mecs c'est mieux en Amérique bah
c'est bien c'est sympa il y en a plein
c'est cool
est-ce que vous auriez épousé Bernadette
Chirac pour qu'elle reste la première
dame de France
tu es marié j'ai une épouse c'est vrai
que Bernadette a des avantages aussi
elle a ses charmes non non mais c'est
clair que j'aurais pu blessé de tenter
là encore je dirais qu'on ne s'est pas
rencontré mais je vous cache pas que il
y a un côté coquin dans son ensemble
vous auriez préféré Kelly Semoun meurt
avant vous quand même
il doit être dans l'affaire à mon avis
vous êtes content de la spéciale des
Enfants de la télé qui vous a été
consacré vendredi dernier sur TF1
ça me donne presque envie de revenir
il y a des choses qui m'émeubles et j'en
parle bon et hélas mais mes petits
camarades
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé avec le
musicien compositeur des mélodies de
Notre-Dame de Paris coachent vous aurez
écoutez les maladies qu'il a fait pour
le petit prince vous m'en direz des
nouvelles
vous avez déclaré euh il faut être
vigilant et résister à la daube qu'on
nous balance est-ce que vous pensez que
Cindy c'est de la daube
non oui oui je voilà je préfère être
franche tu as vu le spectacle non non
je vois des extraits le FBI soupçonne
votre fils d'être l'auteur des messages
terroristes trouvés dans les toilettes
c'est à peine croyable c'est totalement
fou alors vous lui dites est-ce que
c'est toi qui a fait le coup tout à fait
et là il vous répond non
et le prochain film donc je serai un
policier c'est un rôle de composition
cette fois
dites-moi tous les deux là vous auriez
quand même pu finir comme ça d'une
certaine façon Samy on le sait on l'a
dit ici tu as fait de la tôle à 22 ans 3
ans et demi faisait chauffeur de up
c'est con
ce qui est con mais bon je t'ai fait
serrer bibi pareil il paraît que vous
aviez votre vocation pour l'écriture à
la prison de la Santé c'est vrai c'est
ce qu'on dit mais bon
est-ce que vous pouvez maintenant s'il
vous plaît signer ce cadre qui est à moi
euh Picasso marqué Picasso je
m'arrangerai mais écrire à l'envers ça
va être dur hein voilà vous mettez
Picasso voilà pays c'est ah voilà il est
pour moi
une anecdote comme ça mon père écrivait
très mal le français un jour il me
téléphone il me dit viens vite je suis à
Auchan je vais il faut que tu me
remplisse le chèque et j'arrive je
savais pas remplir le chèque moi-même
mondialisation chez nous c'est devenu
banal notre problème comme si notre
problème serait le monde mais c'est pas
le monde notre problème parce que il
faut au contraire le monde et notre
avenir qu'est-ce qui veut dire bébé
qui dirige le monde
[Applaudissements]
dernière question numéro un top 50 des
présentateurs de tout le monde en parle
pas de vous dire un truc très
sérieusement je suis les yeux dans les
yeux je me foute votre film mais j'avais
très envie de vous rencontrer
vous disiez Arafat est un homme fini
l'homme a commis trop d'erreurs
stratégiques je me place même pas sur un
plan moral il n'y a pas une erreur qui
n'est pas fait et aujourd'hui il est
complètement usé effectivement il est
fini c'est sharon est un criminel de
guerre comme Papon non
attendez
vous savez que les Belges
de remettre en question le pouvoir de
Sharon et bien ça irait beaucoup mieux
si vous êtes aussi bon
romancier que commentateur de prendre du
Proche-Orient vos lecteurs sont mal
barrés
ça va vous manquer les Ferrero Roche
d'Or pour les soirées de l'ambassadeur
je n'ai jamais goûté un seul mais
vraiment un seul mais je sais qu'il y a
une pub comme ça
maintenant ma vie
bonsoir mobile donc vous êtes une énorme
star mondiale
vous savez à quoi on a droit quand on
est une énorme star mondiale
[Musique]
dans tout ça vous savez vous savez ce
que c'est ça c'est un piano qui fait des
images
[Musique]
ok play a vendu 10 millions d'albums
mais pour ceux qui connaissent pas
encore à Moby si on a ce qui
m'étonnerait Didier
[Musique]
et le dernier c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
le troisième single extrait de son
dernier album qui s'appelle 18 alors
vous avez 37 ans vous êtes né à New York
dans le quartier de Harlem votre vrai
nom c'est Richard Melville hall et vous
êtes l'arrière petit neveu de Herman
Melville l'auteur de Moby Dick et c'est
pour ça qu'on vous a appelé mobi vous
avez deux ans lorsque votre père meurt
dans une accident de voiture votre mère
déménage dans le Connecticut
là vous êtes né
donc
votre mère déménage dans le
connecticuten Dombasle où elle-même une
vie on peut dire de hippies de Baba
comme on dit ici et en 1968 à l'âge de 3
ans vous rencontrez Marie lafière proud
Mary la chanson de Creedence Clearwater
Revival il a pour vous c'est un choc le
jour où vous entendez ce morceau dans la
vieille plaque complètement déglinguée
sur l'autoradio pourri de la voiture
pour vous c'est le choc c'est la grande
révélation vous souvenez de ce moment-là
il faut penser que c'est un peu bizarre
pour moi d'avoir eu cette expérience là
j'ai trois ans et 34 ans après en parler
dans un show français donc ça c'était à
l'âge de 3 ans à l'âge de 4 ans vous
partez toujours avec votre mère à San
Francisco c'est l'époque du Summer of
Love le fameux été de l'amour
californien et vous avez une enfance
assez bizarre bohème sans fric
j'ai grandi dans une ville très riche
extrêmement riche et ma mère nous étions
du gouvernement on avait des timbres
pour acheter une nourriture
mes amis vivaient dans de très belles
maisons avec des serviteurs et donc j'ai
eu ce sentiment de ne pas être adapté
j'avais l'impression un citoyen de
deuxième zone et encore aujourd'hui j'ai
un peu cette impression dire qu'à
l'époque vos copains ils allaient faire
du ski dans le Colorado et vous vous
restiez pendant toutes les vacances
devant la télévision quoi
l'été par exemple les vacances d'été
tous les amis par terre faire du bateau
de la voile ou ce problème en Suisse et
moi je restais assis à la maison et je
regardais une petite télé en noir et
blanc
j'ai essayé de m'amuser à regarder des
dessins animés et ça durait tout l'été
c'est vraiment très triste on va pleurer
c'est triste mais c'est vrai
et en plus et en plus je tiens petit et
maladie
chétif maladie
vous avez un demi-frère non
c'est moi oui quelque part
que je laisse et que ma mère se marier
elle a eu un enfant
quelque part dans le monde j'ai deux
demi-frères il est même pas un frère
entier et là vous avez appris plus tard
qu'en fait votre père n'était pas mort
dans un accident de voiture mais qui
s'était suicidé à l'âge de 26 ans mon
père
et ce que j'ai découvert j'étais plus
plus vieux beaucoup de gens pensaient
que c'était un suicide
qui avait beaucoup de troubles un jeune
comme je crois Albert Camus s'est tué en
voiture donc c'est
un moyen assez répandu pour pour mourir
pour se suicider
une mort violente alors le seul
échappatoire à cette jeunesse un petit
peu ratée on peut dire c'est la musique
à l'âge de 13 ans vous apprenez à jouer
Cocody rock
à 14 ans vous faites un groupe qui joue
des chansons des Beatles du rock par
exemple birday des choses comme ça et
puis vous découvrez le pain que la new
wave votre idole c'était John Lidl l'ex
Jenny rotten le héros de Pie
qui était vraiment pour vous le summum
lorsque j'ai grandi
peu sûr de moi parce que j'étais très
pauvre dans une vie très riche comme je
vous l'ai dit j'étais très petit dans
une ville pleine de beaux athlètes mais
tout à coup lorsque j'ai eu 14-15 ans
j'ai découvert le pancrack et au lieu de
me sentir un peu à outsider j'ai pensé
que il y avait quelque chose dont je
pouvais être fier parce que la chose
merveilleuse du punk rock il faisait des
vertus du fait d'être un marginal en
fait
en 1983 vous avez votre premier
magnétophone 4 pistes et vous découvrez
effectivement qu'on pouvait faire de la
musique tout seul ça c'est formidable
pour vous
lorsque vous jouez dans un groupe il
faut toujours attendre que les gens
arrivent et les autres musiciens ont des
petites habits où ils sont où ils sont
Souls
donc moi j'étais dans et j'attendais que
les autres musiciens arrivent et j'ai
découvert le miracle de ce 4 pistes et
j'ai réalisé que j'avais pas besoin
d'autres musiciens je pouvais tout faire
moi-même mais comme résultat je n'ai pas
beaucoup de qualité sociale si vous
voulez là ça va relationnel
de formation alors comme vous êtes DJ à
New York vous vous rendez compte de
l'arrivée de la dance de la house et de
la techno et vous vous laissez tomber
dans Rock and Roll pour les musiques
électroniques
était nouveau dans la fin des années 70
le dinde c'était nouveau à la fin des
années 80 et 90 votre premier tube
c'était Go Didier
et aujourd'hui il y a ça
[Musique]
c'est le troisième single extrait de 18
le nouvel album de Moby qui est notre
invité ce soir alors vous adorez les
ragots
avec Tom Cruise
parler de ses qualités d'acteurs et
comment il est devenu un acteur on s'en
avait acheté un exemplaire de journal
c'est la nature humaine peu de gens le
reconnaissent c'est vrai que Britney
Spears est plus vierge
elle avait des rapports sexuels
de la vidéo c'est ce qu'on raconte je
sais pas
sacré Robert
[Applaudissements]
c'était un peu plus excitant que ça
quand même
donc c'est comme des chiens qui baisent
quoi
alors dites-moi vous aimez bien les
ragots mais Eminem avec vous il n'y est
pas les orago lui il a carrément balancé
dans une chanson
[Musique]
Rover
c'est drôle alors je vais je vais dire à
nos amis français je vais traduire donc
il dit en parlant de vous toi le
chauffe-pédé de 36 balais suce moi tu me
connais pas tu es trop vieux pour ça et
chaque soir sur scène il tue un
mannequin à votre effigie
c'est pas très cool
ou j'ai critiqué parce qu'il était
misogyne et un homophobe il a été très
vexé
par contre était drôle ça prouve qu'il a
un certain sens de l'humour à part le
fait qu'il soit misogyne et homophobe je
trouve que son travail est intéressant
je l'ai rencontré quelques semaines à
New York
et c'est pas une blague c'est grave
alors
il voulait vous battre
heureusement heureusement
que vous êtes chrétien et que vous avez
un grand sens de la compassion de
l'humilité
et de l'amour quand même
j'ai suivi pour savoir comment faire des
interviews et on m'a dit que c'était bon
pour mon image d'être plein de
compassion
parce que la vérité c'est que je suis
vraiment un très très méchant
je torture les animaux dans la télé ça
est-ce que vous êtes suffisamment
chrétien pour pardonner à Eminem
je dois le pardonner est-ce que vous
êtes suffisamment chrétien pour quitter
ce plateau sur une musique d'Eminem
oui bien sûr
[Musique]
c'était tout le monde en parle
l'émission qui nous fait plaisir de
payer l'ardevance
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
tube abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu